passer des projecteurs du show-business
au plafonnier d'une smart c'est la
malheureuse expérience qui est arrivé à
la chanteuse ophélie winter dans les
années 90 et 2000 aux fellahs et comme
ses fans aimait l'appeler était une star
qui vendait des centaines de milliers
d'albums en boucle à la radio sur les
chaînes de clips et dans les boîtes de
nuit tout le monde à bouger au son de
fait les winter
[Musique]
mais avec le temps les ventes de disques
se sont effondrées
et si ces dernières années la jeune
femme avait quitté les plateaux télé les
couvertures de la presse people
elle était revenue en 2014 sur tf1 dans
danse avec les stars
et c'est finalement à dubaï que la jeune
femme avait choisi de reconstruire sa
vie au bras de son mari un riche homme
d'affaires hollandais mais la belle
histoire semble avoir tourné court
depuis le mois de mai ophélie est rentré
à paris et ses problèmes financiers
semblent s'être intensifier l aurait
rendu le petit appartement de neuilly
dans lequel elle vivait et depuis dormir
et chez des amis ici et là jusqu'il ya
quelques jours où la presse people
prétend qu'elle aurait été surprise à la
sortie d'un petit hôtel modeste mêmes
qui lui arriverait de dormir dans sa
voiture
une affaire qui fait beaucoup parler
depuis quelques jours
alors au fait du winter est au téléphone
avec nous c'est vrai qu'on en a parlé
voilà c'était jeudi on rappelle donc les
infos de public elle aurait retrouvé
refuge dans sa voiture elle aurait passé
plusieurs nuits dans ophélie winter que
j'adore voilà c'est quelqu'un des gc une
fille exceptionnelle et ophélie est avec
nous bonsoir ophélie salut ophélie c'est
cyril hanouna tu me remets ça va bien
mon ophélie alors on s'est dit c'est
vrai que la télé pour complot sont coupe
tous les sons d'ailleurs comme tous les
sons dernier avec nous merci aux faits
ni au final merci d'être avec nous ce
soir tu es vraiment en amour je sais
qu'ils écoutent suivi me suis vraiment
désolé j'avais j'ai donné ma parole à
lionel cette émission que je serai la
présente je commencer quelque part et je
me méfierais auprès de vous parce que
voilà je suis yann par la pensée le
coeur ont fait l'histoire on a entendu
plein de choses sur toi est-ce que tu
confirmes les informations qu'ils disent
que tu es sans domicile fixe soit ce que
c'est c'est c'est pas tout à fait ça je
suis franchement quand les remords il a
appris chez toi ça m'a fait rire après
ça m'a un peu énervé parce que je pense
qu'il ya d'autres
une nouvelle bien plus qu'intéressante
savoir aurait avec l'usep et quoi mais
je n'habite plus en france et il est
passé presque deux semaines à faire
mario bros avec ma petite smart
on ne demandait rien à personne le
déménagement de le gardeur garde meuble
à garden et genres divers tours avec des
cafés on va pas elle est naïve et
cultuel ya un fou rire à feu rouge il
veut franchir des connaissances
politiques donc donc juste nous faisait
des allers-retours avec ta voiture je
décharge de paix dans l'hôtel mais ne
l'est pas de domicile du tout n'est pas
fixe mobile
il ne vit depuis en france tu n'as pas
de domicile en france c'est tout mais
non ils auraient tort à l'hôtel et voilà
mais combien
scott quand on parle de thé difficulté
tu dont tu dis tu sais c'est c'est
n'importe quoi
et je n'ai parfois pas déjeuner de force
taux qui travaillent pas tutelle pas
d'argent n'étaient pas au top mais on
chante d'ennui gros ennuis et quelqu'un
qu'elle me travailler il m'ennuie un peu
mais c'est pas pour finir on sait que
d'habiter à dubaï pourquoi tu as dû fuir
dubaï
bah on le sait bon ton tantôt piste non
mais pourquoi tu as dû fuir dubaï parce
qu'on sait que tu as dû partir de dubaï
précipitamment pourquoi du pourquoi il
avait toujours à dubaï alors non mais à
l'énergie mais bien parce que tu as des
enfants que je n'ai pas apparemment mon
coeur bat alors donc là tu habites où on
va tenter de vie du pain pâtes look si
pardon c'est les a c'est les infos de
public et public est un journal sérieux
donc je sais pas des fois ils adorent
fois ils ont dit que valérie benaïm à
une moustache
non mais ophélie ont ramé et nous la
vérité parce que on attend plein de
choses dont tu habites à dubaï ou
tamiflu doit la vie privée je te dise
pour je ne sais quelle raison d'accords
en train de me poser des questions parce
que je voudrais monter quatre poches je
vois le pressing laisser des choses mais
c'est certain que je ne peux plus vivre
alors elle pas comment on fait lit nous
en fait tu t'expliques on s'est inquiété
pour toi parce qu'on a vu ça on n'avait
pas de nouvelles de toi donc ses parents
voulaient c'est parce que tu charges de
travail respectable mails moins d'un
mois pour avoir des nouvelles du royaume
a pimenté rigolo bah oui mon arrivée pas
de joindre en plus mon téléphone est
complètement bizarrement avoir un jour
et je vois tu pas plus je peux nous dire
aujourd'hui que tout va bien pour toi
battant des deux bras deux ans le
truchement ça nous permet pas le plat
pourquoi ils pas les quatre parce que ce
dixième on y est c'est pas un budget la
fin j'ai jamais trouvé des personnes
incapables de vouloir faire le bras
articulé de mon cerveau mais tout va
bien pour toi t'as d'état des
propositions
rail mais là je vais faire des choses
moi-même
voilà des choses qui saluait pardon fini
parce que moi je t'avais envoyer des
textos de temps en temps tu réponds très
gentiment et non c'était juste pour
savoir et c'est une bonne nouvelle ça va
bien mais quand tu dis je déménage je
quitte la france est ce que tu pourrais
me dire au moins sur quel continent tu
pars m'installer
mais c'est serré en fait sur et
confirmant la fin de ma faute quand il
arrive même qu'on pense pas qu'il soit
le fils d'un des mineurs comme un sétois
spéciaux on y compte le quart d'une
faction de la chefferie de comprendre
voilà d'accepter fédérale à l'achat
maintenant j'espère suis libre et
reviens et avant safari mais en même
temps je crois que je me serais si
finalement string je suis là ça fera
découvrir à l'état tu fais ce que tu m'
a pas aidés en tentant très mal toi
aussi tu entends pas très bien non mais
juste une audi tt dans la misère totale
aujourd'hui tu dis que ça se marier dans
quelques années alors à new york sistema
quelques années ce serait super c'est
début j'étais qu'il ya du travail par
équipe et tu travailles pas tu ne peux
plus j'ai envie que ma [ __ ] pas jusqu'à
la phase de jeu plus près de la sortie
de l'entraînement que je complète nous
habite dans une plaine et voilà c'est
pas donné mais si sigourre c'est quand
une femme s'aiment c'est sympa d'être
dans des hôtels parce que plus il ya de
la sécurité il ya des gens pour
comprendre tu fais des rencontres
voilà je n'ai pas de chance j'ai pas le
droit de me plaindre soient d'accord
raison qu'ils sont bien bien tant qu'on
a la santé et le comment ça se passe sam
a fait ce matériau est sa matière et en
même temps les fumées wow quelle info
d'accord donc vu que les bons sinon donc
tout va que tout va bien tout va bien
pour moi je veux pas dire que c'est
depuis la fête mais je suis seul
c'était beaucoup de travail j'ai pondu
des problèmes de santé et je vois la mer
à l'arrivée pas les une expérience
voilà je ne peux pas demander de l'aide
des impôts dgi je sais au tennis je sais
qu'on a on a voulu teddy le dio
téléspectateurs pendant que vous luttez
des étudiant es tu veux aucune aide il
paraît que tu veux pas qu'on prenne des
parts de trucs pour l'instant tu veux
aucune aide
mais c'est fini ça fait deux jours lui
parler a perfé d'abord qu'est donc tu
veux connaître pour l'instant fait c'est
ce que tu disais avant jeudi je n'ai
rien dit à personne elle conquérir le
public qui m'a appris à moi et aux en
situation d'alerté sera complètement
aref faux pas ok ok ok non non pardon
vous ayez un boulot parce que je sais
c'est nécessaire ça hyper touchant que
que tu veux pas qu'on t'aide tous à
exxon femme forte mais est-ce que c'est
quelqu'un te proposait un boulot est ce
que tu n'accepteras aujourd'hui que ce
soit chroniqueur dans la télé dans
quelque chose est-ce que tu serais
ouvert à une proposition ou quoi qu'il
arrive tu pars je suis ouverte à tous
est juste comme je t'ai dit d'une sorte
plus je ne vois pas ce que ma vie
personnelle est compliqué quand il fut
assez bien les gens à trouver qui fuit à
ça j'ai voilà c'est un peu triste connu
un petit peu mais c'est l'endroit du
showbiz unifiée montant est en vie quand
on propose des choses qu'il faut pas
alors l'adéquation avec je suis
maintenant d'accord ophélie en tout cas
merci aux faits dit qu'on fait des gros
bisous
[Applaudissements]
voilà merci aux élus mr t on le voit
desquels toi sur le plateau de tpm pire
de carole embrasse très très fort aux
filles je suis vous étiez plein avoir de
ses nouvelles mathieu l'espère vraiment
vraiment que au moins grâce à ce qu'on a
fait là et cet appel
il ya des gens qui du coup conscience
que ça va mal et vont lui proposer du
boulot parce qu'elle est magnifique
parce qu'elle ait du talent parce que
c'est une bonne animatrice parce que
c'est une bonne chanteuse pour l'instant
il faut pas qu'on la voit au feeling je
dis voilà elle veut quand elle l'a dit
d'ailleurs là les propos qu'on peut très
bien comprendre que tu sois pas bien ta
tête tu n'as pas envie qu'on ne voit ça
m'est arrivé c'est de tout apport vu
qu'on le voit mais j'espère en moi qui
les propositions qui vont arriver et qui
vont nous permettre
du coup de se relancer et de retrouver
la gnac pour justement aller mieux et
avoir envie qu'on la voit de nouveau